Cosplayer: Wakanda forever!
Cosplayer: Well, let me
tell you something, dude.
You'd better come down
here to C2E2, brother!
Cosplayer: I think this is
version three of everything
on this costume, and I'm
finally happy with it.
Harley Quinn: Something tells
me a whole lot of people
are about to die.
Cosplayer: Everybody
laugh at Moaning Myrtle!
10 points to get it through her stomach,
50 if you get it through her head!
Cosplayer: I keep getting
those looks, all day.
I walk by, and people are like, "Whoa!"
Cosplayer: Smoke, good!
Cosplayer: Storm,
mistress of the elements,
and I command you to release that child!
Cosplayer: The wings took about two weeks,
this guy was, like, a two-day build,
and this was a one-day build.
Goes like that. [laughs]
Cosplayer: Bakugo, from
"My Hero Academia."
Cosplayer: I made the wig myself,
and I used expanding
foam for the pigtails.
And then I had to screw
them into the wig cap,
so it took probably about
three months, probably more.